Порушення правил паркування в Україні
- практично на кожному кроці.
А до відповідальності у 2016 році притягався
в середньому лише один порушник на день.
Реформа системи паркування покликана змінити ситуацію.
От що чекає на водіїв:
Головне нововведення закону - це впровадження
фото- та відеофіксації.
Недешева фотокартка водія із датою та місцем
порушення надійде рекомендованим листом
на адресу власника автівки.
Ця система фіксації порушень дозволяє уникнути
спілкування поліцейського та водія, що зменшує ризик корупції.
Гроші за неправомірне паркування надходитимуть
в бюджет і, в ідеалі, витрачатимуться на
покращення транспортної інфраструктури.
Нині поліцейський вирішує, чи "суттєво"
ваш автомобіль перешкоджає дорожньому руху
і чи варто його евакуювати.
Із набуттям чинності закону, правоохоронці втрачають ці повноваження.
Закон прописує 17 підстав, коли викликати евакуатор.
А саме, якщо ваш автомобіль припаркований:
- На проїзній частині у два чи більше рядів;
- На залізничному переїзді, трамвайних коліях,
пішохідних переходах, перехрестях чи менш,
ніж за 10 метрів від них;
- На смугах для руху громадського транспорту,
менш ніж за 30 метрів від зупинок;
- На велодоріжках, парковках для людей
з інвалідністю чи для електороавтомобілів;
А також, якщо ваше авто блокує проїзд чи прохід,
перешкоджаючи пересуванню пішоходів.
Штраф через неправильне паркування треба
оплатити протягом 30 днів.
Для добросовісних порушників передбачене
заохочення: сплачуєш штраф протягом 10 днів – знижка 50%!
У разі несплати, ваш автомобіль може арештувати
поліція, а щоб отримати його назад –
треба буде сплатити подвійну суму.
Також мають впровадити автоматизовану систему
контролю оплати паркування.
Проте людський фактор не скасовується цілковито.
Крім автоматичної фото-та відеофіксації,
працюватимутьтакож інспектори, які складатимуть
протоколи та лишатимуть водієві повідомлення
про штраф на лобовому склі.